desafortunadamente hay muchos errores de
concepto que las personas tienen cuando
tratan de resolver problemas con fuerza
centrípeta en este vídeo resolveremos
algunos problemas para desarrollar una
estrategia de resolución de estos así
como revisar algunos de los errores más
comunes que tienen las personas cuando
tratan de resolver problemas de
movimiento circular veamos este problema
imaginemos que una cuerda está haciendo
que este objeto de vueltas y digamos que
este objeto está trazando un círculo
perfecto y se encuentra en una mesa
completamente libre de fricción esta es
la vista por arriba la vista aérea y si
lo hubiéramos de lado luciría así
tenemos la bola la cuerda y esta cuerda
va a estar atada a un palo que se
encuentre clavado en el medio y ya que
la bola está atada la cuerda y la cuerda
está atada al palo vamos a empujar la
bola para que empiece a girar y va a
recorrer esta ruta circular en la mesa
así luce cuando lo vemos de lado pero
desde arriba luce así es la vista que
tendríamos si observáramos la mesa desde
arriba y esta es la vista que tendríamos
si observamos la mesa del lado y ahora
mi pregunta es cuál es la fuerza que
hace que esta bola se mueva en círculo y
muchas personas quieren responder esta
pregunta con la fuerza centrípeta la
fuerza centrípeta que apunta hacia el
centro del círculo y no es incorrecto de
hecho es correcto pero no es todo lo que
ocurre aquí y la razón es que cuando
decimos fuerza centrípeta nos estamos
refiriendo únicamente a una fuerza que
apunta hacia el centro del círculo así
que decir que esta bola siguió una ruta
circular solamente por la fuerza
centrípeta es algo poco satisfactorio es
cómo responder cuál es la fuerza que
equilibra la fuerza de gravedad cuando
se encuentra esta bola encima de la mesa
respondiendo a pues
la fuerza que va hacia arriba y bueno si
sabemos que tiene que ser una fuerza que
va hacia arriba pero esto realmente no
nos dice cuál es esa fuerza de forma
similar decir que esto es causado sólo
por la fuerza centrípeta solo nos dice
hacia donde apunta la fuerza pero no nos
está diciendo cuál fuerza es y para
responder mejor a la pregunta de aquí
cuál es la fuerza que equilibra a la
fuerza de gravedad y evita que la bola
caiga a través de la mesa en lugar de
decir que es una fuerza que va hacia
arriba la respuesta es la fuerza normal
y aquí podemos también responder mejor
en lugar de decir que es la fuerza
centrípeta podríamos decir bueno qué
tipo de fuerza es ésta tiene que ser una
fuerza que ya conocemos tiene que ser la
fuerza normal o la fuerza de fricción o
la fuerza de tensión o incluso la fuerza
de gravedad
la fuerza centrípeta no es un tipo de
fuerza es algunas de las fuerzas que ya
conocemos pero que resulta está
apuntando hacia el centro del círculo y
esto es algo importante ya que este es
uno de los errores más comunes en este
tipo de problemas algunas personas creen
que la fuerza centrípeta es un nuevo
tipo de fuerza pero no lo es es una de
las fuerzas que ya conocemos cuya
dirección es es hacia el centro de una
ruta circular y que también ocasiona que
este objeto se mueva en forma circular
en este caso cuál es esta fuerza bueno
resulta que este objeto está atado a una
cuerda esta cuerda va a jalar de este
objeto y cuando una cuerda jala a esto
le llamamos la fuerza de tensión y esto
está mejor ya que ya sabemos qué tipo de
fuerza es la que está actuando como
fuerza centrípeta y aquí hay que tener
cuidado algunas personas dicen así claro
esta es la fuerza de atención y también
hay una fuerza centrípeta
esto es incorrecto ya que esta fuerza de
atención es la fuerza centrípeta así que
no la vamos a dibujar dos veces sería
como en este caso decir que tenemos la
fuerza normal y también decir que
tenemos una fuerza hacia arriba la
fuerza que va hacia arriba es la fuerza
normal y no la vamos a dibujar otra vez
de igual manera aquí no voy a dibujar
las fuerzas centrípetas dos veces la
atención es la fuerza centrípeta y
aunque es posible tener dos fuerzas que
vayan hacia adentro no sé quizás
tengamos dos cuerdas y ambas tienen
tensiones diferentes pero siempre
tendremos que identificar qué tipo de
fuerza es antes de intentar dibujarla y
quizás ustedes me digan ah sí sí sí ya
entendí la fuerza centrípeta es otro
nombre que le damos a cualquier fuerza
que apunte hacia el centro del círculo
pero cómo es que resuelvo un problema
como este cuál es la estrategia de
solución tengo fuerzas que van hacia
arriba hacia abajo hacia adentro y aquí
vamos a resolver algunos problemas y a
ver qué cosas tenemos qué
en cuenta vamos a poner unos números
aquí vamos a decir que la masa de la
bola es de 2 kilogramos la longitud de
la cuerda es de 0.5 metros y la bola
está viajando a alrededor del círculo
con una rapidez constante de 5 metros
por segundo así que qué tipo de pregunta
nos podríamos hacer con un problema como
este una posible pregunta sería cuál es
la fuerza de tensión en la cuerda y
ahora es un buen momento para que les
diga un secreto el secreto para resolver
cualquier problema de fuerza centrípeta
es la misma estrategia que usamos para
resolver cualquier problema de fuerzas
en otras palabras lo primero que vamos a
hacer es dibujar un diagrama de fuerzas
de calidad
y luego usamos la segunda ley de newton
para una de las direcciones cada vez y
si la dirección que elegimos para
aplicar la segunda ley de newton no nos
da algún resultado pues vamos a hacer lo
mismo solo que aplicando la segunda ley
de newton para otra dirección y una de
estas direcciones nos va a llevar a la
respuesta correcta
en otras palabras vamos a dibujar un
diagrama de fuerzas de calidad es decir
bien hecho aquí hemos dibujado algunas
fuerzas pero está medio desordenado esta
vista lateral nos permite observar mejor
las fuerzas involucradas aquí ya tenemos
la fuerza normal hacia arriba la fuerza
de gravedad hacia abajo y ahora voy a
dibujar la atención hacia adentro
qué es la fuerza que está actuando como
fuerza centrípeta y ahora vamos a usar
la segunda ley de newton para algunas de
estas direcciones qué dirección debemos
elegir bueno esto depende de cuál es la
fuerza que queremos encontrar y en este
caso quiero encontrar la fuerza de
tensión así que aunque yo aquí podría
aplicar la segunda ley de newton para
esta dirección vertical pues la atención
no apunta en esta dirección así que no
voy a elegir esta dirección primero
vamos a ver si podemos resolver esto en
un solo paso y si elegimos esta
dirección horizontal pues va a ser la
dirección centrípeta es decir hacia
adentro del círculo y ya estamos
tratando con la fuerza centrípeta
entonces vamos a tratar con la
aceleración centrípeta si voy a usar la
fuerza centrípeta entonces voy a tener
que usar la aceleración centrípeta es
decir que aquí solo voy a poner aquellas
fuerzas cuya dirección sea hacia el
centro del círculo o hacia fuera del
círculo radialmente y voy a tener la
aceleración centrípeta radio
y aquí conocemos la fórmula para la
aceleración centrípeta que es b al
cuadrado entre r esto queda del lado
izquierdo y esto es algo nuevo cuando
aplicamos la segunda ley de newton para
fuerzas normales siempre vamos a dejar a
del lado izquierdo pero cuando usamos
esta ley para la fuerza centrípeta vamos
a reemplazar a con b al cuadrado entre r
y esto sigue siendo igual a la fuerza me
está en la dirección centrípeta entre la
masa así que qué fuerzas voy a poner
aquí bueno aquí tengo la fuerza normal
la fuerza de tensión la fuerza de
gravedad otro error común es que muchas
personas tratan de poner todas estas
fuerzas aquí la fuerza normal la fuerza
de tensión la fuerza de gravedad y todas
las que se puedan pero recuerden que si
elegimos la dirección centrípeta
centrípeta se refiere solamente a que
apunta hacia el centro del círculo así
que solamente voy a poner aquellas
fuerzas que se dirigen hacia el centro
del círculo
esas no incluyen a la fuerza normal ni a
la fuerza de gravedad la única fuerza
que va hacia el centro del círculo es la
fuerza de tensión y como ya mencionamos
esta es la fuerza centrípeta así que
tengo b al cuadrado / r y esto es igual
a la fuerza de tensión que es mi fuerza
centrípeta y ahora ésta deberá ser
positiva o negativa bueno vamos a tratar
todo lo que vaya hacia adentro como
positivo acaso es posible que alguna
fuerza centrípeta sea negativa lo es si
tenemos alguna fuerza que apunte
radialmente hacia afuera del círculo si
por ejemplo tuviéramos alguna otra
cuerda que estuviera jalando la bola
hacia afuera incluiríamos esta fuerza en
estos cálculos pero con signo negativo
así que las fuerzas que se dirigen fuera
del círculo van a ser negativas
y las fuerzas que van hacia dentro del
círculo serán positivas y si no van
hacia adentro o hacia fuera del círculo
no las vamos a incluir en nuestros
cálculos y quizás ustedes no estén de
acuerdo me pueden decir oye hay una
fuerza que va hacia fuera del círculo
esta bola quiere escapar del círculo por
lo que deberíamos tener una fuerza que
apunte hacia acá y nos referimos a esta
fuerza como fuerza centrífuga y ésta
realmente no existe cuando las personas
se refieren a una fuerza que trata de
sacar de este círculo a este objeto
normalmente se refieren a esta fuerza
centrífuga pero esto no existe no existe
una fuerza natural que apunte hacia
afuera para algo que va en una ruta
circular y ustedes me pueden decir a ver
si yo suelto esta bola va a salir
volando pero no si ustedes soltarán esta
bola o si se rompiera la cuerda esta
bola no se va a ir en esta dirección no
hay alguna fuerza que esté empujando la
bola hacia la derecha
si esta cuerda se rompiera la bola
seguiría la segunda ley de newton
viajaría por acá en línea recta a una
velocidad constante y rodaría fuera de
la mesa así que si tenemos que usar una
cuerda para hacer que esta bola de
vueltas no vamos a tener una fuerza
externa que esté tratando de jalar hacia
afuera la bola simplemente esta bola va
a querer mantener su velocidad tiene
inercia y va a querer moverse en línea
recta pero tenemos que seguir jalando la
para hacer que esta velocidad cambie de
dirección y aunque muchas personas crean
que hay una fuerza que jala la pelota
hacia afuera y que es la fuerza
centrífuga realmente esto no existe
finalmente regreso a mi ecuación pongo
aquí mi masa
y ahora despejo mi fuerza de tensión
para hacer esto multiplico ambos lados
por la masa y me queda que la fuerza de
tensión es igual a la masa por b al
cuadrado entre r y si pongo los valores
la masa es de 2 kilogramos la rapidez es
de 5 metros por segundo todo esto al
cuadrado y el radio del círculo es de
0.5 metros y si hacemos los cálculos nos
queda que la fuerza de tensión es igual
a 100 newtons en este caso la fuerza de
tensión que es la fuerza centrípeta es
igual a 100 newtons y ustedes pueden
decir esto fue demasiado trabajo para un
problema tan simple porque tenemos que
hacer todo este desarrollo de la
estrategia de resolución del problema
estoy de acuerdo que este problema fue
fácil pero otros problemas no van a ser
tan fáciles y si no tenemos una
estrategia definida para solucionar este
problema vamos a estar nos confundiendo
y tratando de hacer cosas aleatorias
para ver si damos con la solución
ahora usaremos la misma estrategia pero
con un problema un poquito más difícil
digamos que tenemos esto estamos
montando nuestra bicicleta y vamos a
pasar por una colina circular esta línea
de aquí representa el pavimento comienza
estando plana pero poco a poco comienza
a seguir esta forma circular así que
aquí tenemos esta colina de concreto por
la que vamos pasando y este círculo
representa la ruta que seguiríamos si
siguiéramos esta dirección tendría esta
forma y tenemos que definir cuál es el
radio de esto pongamos números en este
problema digamos que el radio de esta
colina es de 8 metros y la masa de
nosotros y nuestra bicicleta es de 100
kilogramos y digamos que vamos sobre
esta colina a unos 6 metros por segundo
y aquí queremos saber cuál es el tamaño
de la fuerza normal que es ejercida en
nosotros si nuestra bicicleta conforme
vamos pasando por la cima de esta colina
a 6 metros por segundo
a decir lo que no se debe hacer algunas
personas se verán tentados en decir que
esta fuerza normal es igual a la fuerza
de gravedad y ya que la fuerza de
gravedad es igual a m porque la fuerza
normal también tendrá que ser m por g
pero esto no es así si las fuerzas en un
objeto están equilibradas y se cancelan
el objeto va a mantener su velocidad en
magnitud y dirección y si esta bicicleta
va hacia la derecha seguiría yendo hacia
la derecha y seguiría flotando por
encima de esta colina lo cual sería
genial pero no ocurre esta bicicleta se
mueve hacia abajo acelera hacia abajo y
cómo se mueve hacia abajo la fuerza que
apunta hacia abajo tiene que ser más
grande por lo que la fuerza de gravedad
va a ser más grande que la fuerza normal
ya que de no ser así esta bicicleta
flotaría en el aire como resolvemos este
problema pues usamos la misma estrategia
dibujamos nuestro diagrama de fuerzas
que ya lo hicimos vamos a usar la
segunda ley de newton para una de las
direcciones
la dirección que vamos a elegir es la
dirección vertical y esta dirección
vertical acaso es la dirección
centrípeta pues sí sí lo es porque vean
que se dirige hacia el centro del
círculo esta bicicleta está en la cima
de la colina y hacia abajo va a estar
exactamente el centro del círculo y ya
que estamos tratando con la dirección
sentí que está ponemos la fórmula para
la aceleración centrípeta y la parte
donde tenemos que tener más cuidado es
la parte donde incluimos las fuerzas
centrípetas recuerden que hacia adentro
del círculo es positivo y hacia fuera
radialmente es negativo así que tanto la
fuerza normal como la fuerza de gravedad
van a incluirse pero solo una de ellas
tendrá signo positivo pueden encontrar
cuál de ellas es cual estará incluida
aquí con signo positivo si dijeron que
la fuerza de gravedad es correcta lo
cual es extraño porque normalmente
tratamos a la fuerza de gravedad con
signo negativo ya que apunta hacia abajo
pero
en esta fuerza centrípeta lo que nos
interesa es y va hacia adentro o hacia
afuera del círculo asi que ponemos a la
gravedad con una fuerza centrípeta
positiva pues es la fuerza que apunta
hacia el centro del círculo y en este
caso de la fuerza normal va a ser una
fuerza centrípeta negativa pues va hacia
afuera del centro del círculo dividimos
entre la masa y vamos a despejar nuestra
fuerza normal multiplicamos ambos lados
por m movemos la fn y movemos m por b al
cuadrado entre r al otro lado y nos
queda que la fuerza de tensión es igual
a m por g menos m por b al cuadrado
entre r si ponemos números nos queda 100
kilogramos por 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado menos 100 kilogramos por 6
metros por segundo al cuadrado dividido
entre el radio del círculo en el que
estamos viajando que es de 8 metros y
nos va a dar todo esto 530 newtons así
que la fuerza normal que actúa sobre
nosotros y nuestra bicicleta
estamos por encima de esta colina para
ser de 530 newtons y esto no es igual a
nuestro peso esto es menor que nuestro
peso la fuerza de gravedad en nosotros
es m por g que va a ser como 980 newtons
por lo que aquí vamos a experimentar una
fuerza normal menor y esto es natural es
lo que sucede cuando pasamos por una
colina rápidamente nos sentimos
ligeramente menos pesados cuando estamos
pasando por encima de la colina quizás
les ha pasado cuando van en un auto y
pasan rápidamente por encima de una
colina cuando van bajando sienten en el
estómago así como que wow esto se siente
genial
esta es la falta de peso que sentimos
durante un momento y si vamos muy rápido
esta fuerza normal va a ser cero si
restamos lo suficiente m por b al
cuadrado entre r la fuerza normal será
cero y cuando esto ocurre comenzamos a
volar así que tengan cuidado cuando
pasen por estas colinas si pasan muy
rápido van a volar porque su fuerza
normal va a ser cero en resumen cuando
estamos
resolviendo problemas de fuerza
centrípeta asegúrense de dibujar un buen
diagrama de fuerzas después usen la
segunda ley de newton para una de las
direcciones de estas fuerzas si usa la
dirección centrípeta la dirección que
apunta radialmente hacia el centro del
círculo pueden decir que la aceleración
en esa dirección es igual a b cuadrada /
r
pero asegúrense de solo incluir aquellas
fuerzas que tengan esta dirección
centrípeta cuya dirección sea radial es
decir fuerzas que apunten hacia adentro
o hacia afuera del círculo si apuntan
hacia adentro del círculo serán
positivas y se apuntan hacia fuera del
círculo serán negativas